Film Courage: When do you start writing everyday?
Jeffrey Reddick, Screenwriter: About 11:00
a.m.
I usually roll out of bed and have my routine
where I’ll say some prayers, meditate a
little (not much), read the news, see what’s
going on, and pack up and usually go over
to the coffee shop and start writing.
But I’m also a night owl, too.
So I stay up late writing.
So it’s sporadic because I am usually working,
juggling like four or five different things
at one time.
I’m usually hopping around to make sure
I’m on top of whatever needs to be done
first.
Film Courage: How long are you writing for?
Jeffrey Reddick: It’s on and off pretty
much all day.
I mean, I’ll be up late watching TV but
still have my laptop on writing a little bit.
It depends, if I have a writing assignment
then I’ll be more structured in it as far
as I will focus more on that and then try
to like have fun and have a life the rest
of the time that I’m not writing.
But if I’m in a stage where I’m like working
on four or five different things trying to
get them off the ground, I’m usually writing
quite a bit.
Film Courage: Interesting.
So you got to the coffee shop, do you ever
write here [referring to Jeffrey’s place]?
Jeffrey Reddick: Sometimes but if I stay here
I get very distracted like I want to watch
TV, I want to take a nap, I’m very comfortable
here.
I like to go to the coffee shop because I
get my socializing done too because I have
friends there and stuff like that.
So I like to get out and do that, as well.
Film Courage: Are there a lot of regulars
there, too?
Jeffery Reddick: Yeah.
There’s a lot of the.
A lot of writers.
Film Courage: Nice.
Do they ask you what you’re writing?
Or no one really asks that they just kind
of know.
Jeffery Reddick: Yeah, people will talk to
you.
Especially if you go there a long time and
you’ve made friends with people they kind
of know what you’re up to and if they follow
you on social media and you’re talking about
stuff, they will ask you about what you’re
doing and things like that.
It’s fun.
It’s very transitory though, too.
Because there’s a couple regulars but a
lot of the writers if they move they will
go to another coffee shop or they’ll go
work at the WGA.
It has a space to work at or people rent spaces
now.
Which I’m actually thinking about doing
because I think I broke it down and I forgot
what the place is called but there’s a company
where you can go rent an office space (and
can’t remember the name).
But I did the math and it’s like oh well
for a cup of Starbuck’s coffee and a donut
every day, I can actually rent this place
for a month and they have free coffee all
day.
But I drink tea so I have to check and make
sure they have tea.
Film Courage: It’s probably not as good
as Starbucks.
Jeffery Reddick: No but it’s cool.
You can get a desk and a computer (you have
your own little spot).
It does kind of put you in a different mindset
if you’re leaving your own place to go to
work because even if I’m walking to Starbucks,
even if I’m going there to work and I’m
going there to see my friends and I’m going
to be distracted and you never know what’s
going to happen.
There is some wisdom to having a writing space
that’s an office.
I’ll do that at some point.
I haven’t done that yet.
But I’ll have a place where I’ll have
an office that’s just a separate building
aside from where I am living.
Film Courage: Yeah, I was always opposed to
coffee shop writing for the longest time and
then I noticed that if you have headphones
on and you can still sort of see what’s
going on around you, it’s actually invigorating
(whatever you are working on).
Even if you’re not screenwriting, you’re
just working on something.
Jeffery Reddick: Yeah, you’ve got to have
headphones because they’re important because
people will obviously start talking to you.
Film Courage: Oh that’s true!
It’s a good buffer.
It’s a good social buffer to have those
on.
But also libraries, too.
I’m just surprised that it actually does
feed you and I was opposed to it for the longest
time.
And I can tell now why people need to get
out of the house.
Jeffery Reddick: You need that little segue
from being in your home to your brain going
“Hey, we’re going to work now.”
And if I’m just going from my bedroom to
the living room it’s hard to just sit over
here and say “Okay, turn on my work brain.”
Because I’m like “Wait, what’s on TV?
I’m going to take a nap really quick.”
Film Courage: Right or if I see an interesting
article on like Flipboard or Pocket or something
and then I’m like “Let me just read this.”
And then I’m distracted.
Jeffery Reddick: One you get derailed it’s
kind of hard to get the focus back again.
Film Courage: Would you say you’re very
disciplined when you know that you need to
get these four things done that you’re pretty
good?
Jeffery Reddick: Yeah, I think my friends
think I’m more disciplined than I am.
I think I could probably be more disciplined.
I do work hard though but it’s…I guess
I am, but in my brain I’m not disciplined
enough and my friends are like “You’re
so disciplined.”
I feel like I’d be doing more if I was more
disciplined but I’m usually always juggling
a lot at the same time.
But you always want to make sure that you
don’t have more on your plate than you can
really dedicate quality time to.
I’ve definitely learned the art of saying
no as I’ve gotten older.
Because when you’re young you want to say
yes to everything because you know these could
be my three opportunities, the few things
I ever get.
So you always want to be saying yes to everything.
And as you get older you start realizing that
it’s okay to say no to stuff you’re not
passionate about.
Or if you don’t think you’ll have the
time to really do it and I’ve done that
where I’m like this really isn’t my thing
and I don’t think I’m the best writer
for it.
I know a lot of writers who will take jobs
just to have a job.
Unless I think it’s something that I could
do justice to I’m not going to take it on
as a job unless it’s a challenge.
Sometimes there have been things where people
have brought me projects where I’m like
this isn’t my wheelhouse but it would be
really fun to try to write it so then I’ll
do that.
But it’s got to be something that really
strikes a chord with me.
Film Courage: Do you know any writers that
write eight to ten hours a day?
Jeffery Reddick: Yeah.
Yeah.
Film Courage: Okay.
So I’m assuming they stop for lunch or they
do something.
Jeffery Reddick: Yeah.
I have a lot of writer friends that if they’re
not on staff they very much treat it like
a 9-5 job.
They’ll get up in the morning, they’ll
do there thing, write until lunch time, they’ll
take lunch, they will write to 5:00 p.m. and
then they will stop writing for the say.
And again, I think that’s great if you’re
working on one thing at a time, I think you
have the luxury of doing that more.
I think if you’re trying to do two or three
projects at the same time, then it’s harder
to do that.
But you can do it.
You know I certainly have friends that do
it.